a virus
Florida Florida Florida known for its
sunshine old folks and those Florida man
stories you know Florida is one of
several states trying to open its
economy and for coastal cities that
means their lifeblood the beaches but
I've been living with my Florida parents
and I couldn't imagine going out to the
beach right now it felt too soon but
when my co-workers heard the beaches
were reopening there was some
disagreement I lived in Florida for four
years they 100 with infinite that people
will be there crowded at slipping in
that part its Tampa area healing the
party here going out I will put all my
money on it it's also gonna be a Monday
Monday Monday is our beach days every
day is the beach day just over there I
did look up the weather it looks nice
it's not if you cry I have faith in
Floridians I got up at the crack of dawn
and bike to the grand reopening of the
beach expecting to see crowds of people
here to come back but I'm really tired
and no one's here but these goddamn
Fiegel and they definitely want social
distancing I thought I saw a sheriff
patrolling the Turtle cops honestly this
isn't what I expected and I'm really
impressed with the Floridians here for
not being here I guess well when I got
back my mom wasn't convinced there's my
mom I just got that thanks for opening
would you be surprised to hear that
there was like nobody at the beach well
not really cuz it's like 7 a.m. right go
back in a couple hours I bet it will be
Terry
okay I'll go back in a couple hours but
I think people will still be pretty good
I hope you there be thongs that people
just then I hope people will be staying
apart for each other well say we would
see but first I had to interview someone
official luckily my mom had some
surprising connections mom can you say
what you just said again you know the
former mayor lives right down the street
I did not know that do you think she
would love me interviewer she's a really
nice person I do okay since I'm not
really allowed to interview anyone in
the traditional method I'm gonna try
this or see if I can turn it into
something I rigged up a paddle Mike will
you look at that pretty cool test it on
the dog you don't bite it
don't fight it okay so I'm bringing my
mom to be my assistant camera up and we
are going to interview the former mayor
of st. Pete to see what she thinks about
the beaches she said going through the
back gate feels like we're doing
something illegal again unfortunately
the Romeo and Juliet set up lift it up
higher didn't really work we're gonna
have to do the phone call so I
interviewed her via cell phone in
Florida 1985 and I confirm a 50-seat
Florida so it claims decision so the
local government had to make in
the responsibilities of surely
publishing their car keys where ma'am so
this the governor opens the beaches
ahead right now that we're gonna do that
do you feel like they waited long enough
to reopen the beaches I'm not sure only
because I don't want people to think
that the pandemic still ongoing
we really need turns out that turns out
people fell I like everybody else must
be cautious about get out of there I
hope thank you
after talking to Deb I realized I had to
go back to the beach to see what was
really going on
so my mom and I left to scope it out in
two hours later it was shocking to me
this is the time of year when the
weekends are busy but the weekdays are
usually a bit common these are obviously
rushing to the beaches do you think
people are calling the six feet roller
you
it does not look like it for me this
looks like it too you know yeah he gave
me the walk through it that's about six
feet I wanted to see if people were
staying six feet away so I brought my
six foot paddle but it honestly seemed
too busy for that really it felt like a
normal day and that's what made me
nervous I do worry that people coming
here with the beaches will make make
people more relaxed about their safety
in all areas of life not just coming to
the beach like that they won't be taking
quite as big precautions as they should
be at the grocery stores and things like
that hope that we don't see what happens
during spring week I hope people really
wear masks and stay six feet apart so
after I got back I called dr. mark I'm
CEO of disaster doc and a former CDC
disaster scientist I was the incident
manager there for anthrax and as well as
the Indian Ocean tsunami so Florida
beaches are reopening are you concerned
yes I think that many people are
concerned actually do you think it's too
soon yeah absolutely and what our best
science is telling us is that it is
indeed too soon to reopen especially
when we're talking about the beaches in
Florida cases are increasing they're not
decreasing as they should be and that's
really our defining criteria for
reopening is the symptoms the cases and
the status of the hospitals so those are
the three different things that we look
for and that needs to show a 14 day
decrease it tells us what we need to do
in order to cross these gates and each
phase has a gate so here we are studying
in the first phase and we need to earn
our way to the next that next gate okay
so you're saying Florida just kind of
jumped over the gates instead of opening
the gate that's it yeah you know I mean
they must be in good shape to jump the
gate right that doesn't make sense to me
because Florida it has a much older
population on average that's a good
point perhaps there are ways that the
beach is maybe safe but it's very
problematic and difficult to do so when
you go from absolutely close to
absolutely open mike tyson said everyone
has a plan until you get punched in the
face and you
science has a familiar similar way of
waking us up with a punch in the face at
the fellow Floridian to help them can I
do have to punch them in the face to get
them to know or is there another way I
can help write the word out right I bet
you know I'm not as successful as Mike
was with punching people in the face I
think the information is actually the
great information right I tried to
symbolically punch my fellow Floridians
in the face with facts
I voted out toward the beaches and
attempted to inform the public what I
learned continue to wear your masks
coronavirus can still read outside
nobody seemed to be listening that or my
font it was too small is the issue of
reopening beaches could potentially
cause a spike in these corona cases it's
just difficult to maintain and control a
social distancing of six feet and our
breaths actually carry a cloud of this
virus and when two people stand within
six feet of each other actually that
cloud collects between the two and we
share that cloud in our inhale when we
pass by people that may pass us on the
beach their cloud actually passes
through our cloud and we can breathe in
those things as well requiring people to
stay apart from each other and enforcing
that could help people to reopen the
beach and maintain it safely but once
again I'm not the expert on enforcing
that on a bun 35 mile beach right my mom
texted me in the middle of the interview
to tell me the police had actually shut
down the beach to everyone but locals
because it had reached over a hundred
percent capacity down a pastor grill the
City Commission decided to open 700 of
the 1,000 parking spots that they have
down there that means 300 are closed it
quickly reached capacity and we had to
shut off pastor grill this morning to
only residents down there showing just
how difficult it is to keep beach goers
from going to the beach and that
certainly freaked me out so if you
really want to go to the beach I mean
what can you do you should social
distance not the kind of sneaky
maybe it's six feet maybe it's not
scientists have done studies where these
viruses that
we travel in the air 23 this 27 feet has
been the has been that God distances
please always wear a mask but you think
people on the beach should be wearing
masks I do I do I think so absolutely
how are they gonna avoid the tan line
yeah exactly
is there any concern about spreading
coronavirus when you're in the water I I
have no no no that's good to know
so if you must go to the beach don't sit
still because the longer that you spend
with other people you will [ __ ] have
more likelihood of sharing your breath
beaches tend to pack people into smaller
areas and that's how we catch the virus
well thank you very much my pleasure
honestly I probably won't be going back
to the beach and lounging around anytime
soon but I did want to try to enjoy the
beach in the safest way possible so I
waited until the end of the day and I
follow dr. Klein's instructions we're a
mess say six feet preferably more away
and if you must go keep moving I know
the waters safe over 90 is he going away
anytime soon
you don't ignore that fear use it let it
make you smarter get the hell out of
here okay I don't to get coronavirus
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]